la reconnaissance du vote blanc une
proposition qui émerge du grand débat
national
mais cette revendication est bien plus
vieille retour dans les années 90
actuellement le vote blanc n'est pas
reconnue c'est à dire que quand les gens
votent blanc c'est-à-dire font la
démarche d'aller à l'urne ce qui est
déjà important ça démontre une volonté
civique de participer à la vie du pays
et bien leur vote leur suffrage est
assimilé au vote nul
au même titre que quelqu'un qui mur qui
ratures au pérou ou quoi que ce soit sur
son butin ce n'est pas sain pour une
démocratie
cet homme c'est gérard gautier
communicants de profession il a créé le
mouvement plan s'est exprimée en 1989
son but que le vote blanc soit reconnu
et comptabilisés dans les suffrages
exprimés il lance même un parti il fait
campagne et les français ne semblent pas
contre bien au contraire c'est autre
chose intéressant parce que bon bah
jusqu'à présent c'est vrai que le vote
blanc me le représente rien du tout quoi
et puis bon bah si on n'est pas d'accord
ça permet d'exprimer qu'on n'est pas
d'accord
gérard gautier est loin d'être le seul a
milité pour la reconnaissance du vote
blanc
d'autres citoyens ont lancé leur
mouvement et pas moins de 60
propositions de loi ont été introduites
depuis 1958 et finalement une loi votée
en 2013 la reconnaissance du vote blanc
fait l'unanimité à l'assemblée nationale
les députés l'ont adopté aujourd'hui ces
huit pays le parti de jean-louis borloo
qui a défendu cette mesure pour la
première fois les bulletins blancs sont
différenciés des bulletins nuls
c'est une victoire en demi-teinte pour
les militants car si le vote blanc n'est
plus considéré comme nul
il n'est pas pour autant comptabilisés
dans les suffrages exprimés
si le vote blanc étaient comptabilisés
parmi le suffrage exprimé aujourd'hui
très clairement il pourrait invalider
une élection et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que ça pose problème
il ya eu de nombreuses loin qui sont
passés sur le vote blanc aucune jusqu'à
présent n'a permis que ce vote blanc
puisse avoir ce pouvoir là d'après les
politologues si les votes blancs avaient
été comptabilisés dans les suffrages
exprimés les élections de jacques chirac
en 1995 et celle de françois hollande en
2012 qui n'auraient pas pu être validé
faute de majorité absolue et emmanuel
macron aurait gagné avec 60% des voix et
non pas 60 6%
[Musique]